[Music]
I you like to play with knives well I
ain't play no more you're going to give
me the kill switch and we're going to
end all this come I get it
hero
welcome home
honey do you read now what is this it's
classified come with you oh I'm sorry
you weren't invited
Ohad bad bad behavior nothing can stop
me I Can't Get Enough playing with
dangerous bad behavior bad bad
behavior they call it bad
behavior hey why are you here I got a
situation where I need your help I need
bad
friends was that the new guy this that
sniper don't worry about it I got a
prescription scope oh guys remember this
face don't shoot it by
accident terrorist have taken possession
of nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off
the
coast if these babies go off it'll be
World War
I take
J
to choose his life over
friends over
family It's Time to Get
Loud let's fly
[Music]
baby I'm going to win choose not to life
of imitation this constitute the
reservation now that's what I'm talking
about get get get get
[Music]
is that the biggest one you've
got oh it's way bigger than
[Music]
that